The difference between TikTok and Instagram
will never cease to astound me.
I posted a boudoir photo shoot
that me and my husband did
over on Instagram for Valentine's Day.
It was like,
it was very covered,
it was very tasteful,
it was very fun and sexy.
I wanna say, like,
most people loved it.
I think most people got the vibe.
But I lost probably like
three or four hundred followers from that post alone.
And I think there's such an interesting subtext of
when a woman is married
and a woman is a mother,
there's this expectation of this purity to her.
I don't think people love seeing,
like, sexuality
being exuded by people who are wives and mothers.
And I understand that posting those types of photos
is not gonna be something everybody wants to do.
Not everybody is like
an exhibitionist in that kind of way.
But I've talked on this before
on this app,
that there is this, like,
double standard
that women should be very sexy and sexual
up until they're married and have kids.
But, like, how do you think we got all these kids